hey what's up everyone and welcome to
another hd tutorial and this one's
actually going to be a quick one but it
does have a few cool tips in it that you
guys might want to check out and yes
this tip does work for mac and pc so
let's get right into it uh this one's
actually internet based as you can see
by the title it's going to be about
google's conversions it has two quick
tips that i want to show you one of them
is
google
conversions like in actual units and the
other is translation so the first one
we're going to go to is translation so
if you go over to google.com you've
probably gone there before just hover
and click over the more button and then
go to the even more tab
here you're going to find a lot of
google's options and a ton of things i'm
not actually going to go over pretty
much all of them in my videos to come
because there's a lot of cool things
here
we're going to scroll down here excuse
me we're going to scroll down here
until we get to translation now or
translate this is going to allow us to
number one view web pages in different
languages so if you come across a french
website and you want to read it in
english you can do that well if we just
hit translate here you can actually
translate uh things that you're reading
in english or that you want to write in
english into a different language so if
you want to say
hi i'll just type hi my name
is marcus and we want to translate this
from english to um
we're going to translate this to dutch
to talk to our dutch friend we hit the
translate button and there we go we can
um obviously get a better translation if
we know dutch we can contribute to a
better translation there you go
hollow me i'm not even going to try but
there you go you can obviously sweat
swap it back and forth so if you know
dutch and you want to translate it to
english you can do that by default it is
from english to spanish so it's just a
really cool tool that a lot of people um
have used and have uh decided to uh
utilize in their spanish project or
whatever so i'm going to say hi i like
to play
golf
i said gold
golf and there you go look in the right
hand side that is how i say hi i like to
play golf in japanese so there you go
that's just one of the two things um
you can also obviously translate a
search so if you do fi if you are
searching google and you find a
brazilian result you can actually see
you there you go the original japan
japanese is on the right hand side and
the english translation is on the
left-hand side so that's that's pretty
cool and last but not least you can uh
view a web page in a different language
so let's go back to google and right now
the second thing i want to go over is
trans no what do we call it's
conversions so
uh the in the standard english unit in
the united states is uh the english
system so i like maybe i'm used to
measuring things in pounds but i got a
package today and they said it would be
four kilograms so i want to see how much
that is in pounds so i'm just gonna go
to the google search here and type in 4
kilograms in
pounds
hit enter and we get an exact
translation
8.81849049 pounds okay so that's um it's
really cool it gives you the first
result obviously it's going to be your
result the same thing will work from
pounds to kilograms from liters to
milliliters from um
gallons to quarts i mean it's really
really accurate as well so if i say five
gallons
in quartz
um no that's yeah how many courses five
gallons also wikipedia does this thing
where their first result is always the
translation so how many quarts are five
gallons 20 quarts so there you go
um so wikipedia is always the first
answer and if that is not the first
answer then your google calculator will
be the first answer so eight pounds or
actually we'll do degrees this time two
fair oh i can't expose fahrenheit two
celsius
in
f because i can't spell fahrenheit and
there we go i spelled celsius wrong and
it's 35.6 degrees fahrenheit so it is
extremely accurate and i do recommend
this if you guys are looking to change
units or change time or just learn a
little more about a different culture or
something so there you go you can
definitely i mean there's a whole lot of
google tools but first of all you can
put in a whole bunch of stuff search it
and the first result you'll get is the
answer in the calculator so yeah i hope
you guys like this quick little hd
tutorial not so much a tutorial but a
tip also i'm going to be teaching you
guys how to make this sweet background i
did make this in [ __ ] and it did only
take about eight or nine minutes but
i'll show you guys how to make that too
so again thanks for watching thanks for
checking out my videos and if you can
hit the subscribe button i'd really
appreciate it and thanks for watching
peace